Hallo, Leile ist mein Name und ich bin eine Destationsärztin.
Ja, heute bin ich für Sie zuständig und wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind, würde ich gerne dieses Aufnahmengeschwärte sprechen.
Ja, ich bin einverstanden.
Und jetzt werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Personen stellen und danach ja, um wir sofort zu Ihren Abtäern beschwerden.
Ja.
Okay.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Jutta Husemann.
Jutta Busemann.
Jutta Husemann mit H, Husemann.
Husemann.
Husemann, ja.
Braub Husemann, ja, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41.
41.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 16. September 1982.
1983.
1982.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
60.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
63 kg.
Okay.
Und was fühlt sich zu uns?
Wie können Sie ihn haben?
Ja, ich habe so ungefähr seit zwei Wochen bemerke ich Sehstörungen,
dass ich nicht mehr gut sehen kann.
Es ist so verschwommen.
Teilweise sehe ich auch Doppelbilder.
Hauptsache ist, wie wenn ich durch eine Milchglassescheibe schaue.
Also wie im Nebel.
Okay.
Diese Sehstörungen, ja, erst vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten.
Circa seit zwei Wochen, ja.
Und ist schon langsam, hat sich versteckt?
Ja, das hat sich langsam entwickelt.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie vorher auch die Sehstörungen genaue?
Oder habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt so etwas?
Was ist das?
Erst mal auch getreten.
Okay.
Dann, so, haben Sie so setzliche Barschewerte?
Oder haben Sie schon?
Ja, manchmal Beinschmerzen, so ganz eigenartige Beinschmerzen.
Mehr im linken Bein, aber auch etwas im rechten Bein.
Das ist so unangenehm, besonders auch in der Nacht.
Okay.
Und dieser Beinschmerzen ist auch gleichzeitig aufgetreten?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass das ziemlich gleichzeitig war.
Ja.
Und haben Sie damit, dass Ihre Beine schon geschwollen ist?
Nein, sie sind nicht geschwollen.
Und oder ja, Verfahrung oder so eine ähnliche Barschewerte?
Ich habe zwar oft kalte Füße, aber das habe ich schon immer.
Aber es hat sich nichts verändert so vom Sehen her.
Sie sind nicht geschwollen und nicht rot oder nicht dunkel.
Keine Entzündung, aber sie tun weh.
Okay.
Und Sehstellung zusätzlich?
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder?
Kopfschmerzen nicht, aber ich habe manchmal den Eindruck,
wenn ich etwas länger sprechen muss, dann wird meine Stimme irgendwie,
kann ich nicht immer gut aussprechen.
Das fällt mir schwer, die Wörter auszusprechen.
Und das fällt auch meinen Arbeitskollegen auf,
die gesagt haben, dass manchmal dann meine Sprache so etwas, ja.
Langsam oder?
Waschen.
Wie verwaschen?
Okay.
Und ja,
denken Sie, dass Sie ja ein bisschen leichter anstrengend sind,
ja ermüddend sind?
Ja, ich bin schon etwas, in letzter Zeit etwas schneller müde.
Das merke ich, wenn ich Sport mache.
Ich mache zweimal in der Woche Fitnessstudio.
Und in letzter Zeit kann ich nicht mehr so die Übungen so machen,
wie ich es gewohnt bin.
Das trenkt mich sehr an.
Leiden Sie an krönchenheitkrankungen?
Ach so, ich wollte noch sagen, ich habe auch mal so ein Kribbeln im Bein,
besonders links im Bein, das kribbelt manchmal so.
Und dann habe ich noch festgestellt, dass beim Wasserlassen,
ich den Urin, das Wasser nicht so gut halten kann am Ende.
Es geht immer etwas dann in die Unterhose.
Das ist ja, Entschuldigung, können Sie das, können Sie am Ende,
ja, können Sie nicht kontrollieren, was er lassen?
Nicht so gut, ich versuche es zu stoppen, aber ich beeindruck,
das gelingt mir nicht mehr so, sonst war das immer in Ordnung.
Okay, und, okay, ja, können Sie bis zum Toilette gehen oder das klappt ja nicht?
Toilette, wenn ich den Druck habe auf der Blase,
kann ich Wasser lassen, aber das Ende kann ich nicht kontrollieren.
Dann ist immer etwas übrig.
Okay, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit der Kindheit habe ich Zucker, das nennt sich, glaube ich,
jugendlicher Zucker, da muss ich ins Olin spritzen.
Ja, Schema.
Okay, und das war einzige Krankheit oder hatten Sie auch noch?
Ich habe auch noch so eine chronische Schildrüssenentzündung.
So ungefähr seit 20 Jahren, vor 20 Jahren wurde das festgestellt
und da muss ich dann auch in eine Tablette nehmen.
Okay, Schildrüssen, ja, das ist ja Schildrüssenunterfunktion, hatten Sie?
Ja, und es sei eine chronische Schildrüssenentzündung.
Okay, und ja, da stellen wir die Kammer an, da nehmen Sie ein.
Ja, einmal mein Insulin, das habe ich nach Plan, dann messe ich da vorher den Zucker,
wieviel ich dann spritzen muss, den Plan habe ich damit.
Dann nehme ich für die Schildrüssen noch das Mittel heißt eutirox und grob 50,
eine morgens.
50 microgramm.
Okay, und ja, chronische Schildrüssenentzündung, glaube ich.
Okay, und haben Sie noch etwas?
Nein, ich bin als Kind noch operiert worden am Blinddarm,
ich bin seit 10 Jahren alt, aber sonst bin ich bisher nicht operiert worden.
Das war einzige Operation, ist der Blinddarm.
Okay, in Kindheit, oder Jugendheit, wann sind Sie operiert worden?
In Zucker, und der begleitet mich mein ganzes Leben bisher, Frist.
Ja, ich meine, ich schuldigung, diese Blinddarm-Entfernung,
von 10 Jahren, mit 10 Jahren.
Mit 10 Jahren, schuldigung.
Okay, und ja, in den letzten Zeiten haben Sie ungewollt,
ob oder zugenommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Und nach Schwitzen, oder ich weiß ausruhig, haben Sie so einen?
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme beim Stolkank?
Nein, ich bin schuldig.
Ich bin, wie gesagt, nur beim Wasser lassen, aber beim Stolkank ist halt nicht.
Okay, und ja, haben Sie, oder wie ist Ihre Appetit, ist schon geändert?
Ja, der Appetit ist auch nicht gut, ich kann auch alles essen,
aber ich versuche, möglichst leicht zu essen,
und muss mich ein bisschen wegen meinem Zucker auch regelmäßig
Mahlzeiten nehmen.
Okay, ist Ihre Blutzucker schon gut eingestagt?
Ja, ich gehe auch regelmäßig zu einem Diabetologen,
der ist so weit zufrieden.
Okay, alles in Ordnung.
Okay, und so, haben Sie schon, schuldigung, haben Sie Allergie?
Nein, Allergie habe ich nicht.
Und auch irgendeine Unfallschrecklichkeit?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Und auch in Sie?
Nein.
Alkohol?
Und ja, das ist eine Routinefrage, das nehmen Sie mich denn nicht,
also nicht, haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, und ja, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, mein Vater ist 76 Jahre alt und, ja, den geht es ganz gut,
er hat etwas hohen Blutdruck und hatte vor, glaube ich, 10 Jahren,
er hatte einen Herzinfarkt, aber das ist alles ganz gut verlaufen
und er fühlt sich ganz gut.
Okay, und, da hier, Mutter?
Ja, er ist 43 Jahre alt, die hat einen Alterszucker
und sie hat schwere Atrose in den Knien.
Knienhatrosa und Blutzka.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ein Bruder, der ist 43 Jahre alt, der hat Gicht
und hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Eine Schwester, die ist 39 Jahre alt, die ist gesund.
Okay, und, arbeiten Sie?
Ja, ich bin von Beruf Zahntechnikerin.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, aber ich habe keine Kinder.
Und, ja, wie ist Ihre Stress am Leidensee, unter Stress?
Oder, wie nennen Sie das?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich führe ich ein zufriedenes Leben.
Meine Arbeit macht mir Spaß und gefällt mir.
Die Stress habe ich nicht.
Ja, das hört ja gut an.
Okay, und so, haben Sie diese Sehs...
Erst, ja, versich kurz zusammen die Beschwerde.
Haben Sie jetzt seit zwei Wochen eine Sehsichterung
und, ja, es ist schon...
manchmal sehen Sie, wie duckel und leiden Sie unter
auch Leistungsklinge oder, ja, Ihre Stimme ist ein bisschen...
wenn Sie länger sprechen wollen, dann geht ein bisschen
verwarschender Stimme oder verwarschender Sprache haben Sie.
Und Sie haben auch Beinschmerzen in dieser Zeitraum
und ein bisschen Kribbeln am Beinen.
Und haben Sie auch Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Ja, am Ende kontrollieren Sie das nicht.
Okay, und so, diese Bische waren,
hatten Sie schon mal gehabt oder das ist...
Das ist jetzt ganz neu, seit zwei Wochen.
Vorher hatte ich sowas nicht.
Und ja, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Vorsorge
unter Suchung war?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin
und Hausarzt, lasse mein Blut kontrollieren,
alle Vierteljahre, erwegen auch den Zucker,
Langzeitwert, die Blutfette und gehe einmal zum Diabetologen.
Das mache ich alles regelmäßig.
Okay, okay.
Das war es.
Und so, jetzt, ja,
werde ich die unbedingt untersuchen
und dann, ja, mit dem Befunder,
sprich ich mit meinem Unterarzt
und ja, dann sehen wir,
was diese Bischöwer verursachen.
Was können wir sein?
Was können wir dahinter stecken?
Ja, es gibt viele unterschiedliche Dinge,
aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass Sie, ja,
die miestanische Griffs haben.
Das ist eine, ja,
Ihre Narven geht immer schneller müde.
So kann ich erzählen, ganz kurz.
Okay, gut, dann können wir das so machen.
Dann machen wir es.
Okay, gut.
Wie lange brauchen Sie zum zusammenfassen?
5 Minuten.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ja, ich habe.
Haben Sie Fieber, Störfrost, Nachschweiß?
Ich habe kein Fieber und kein Schüttelfrost.
Nachschweiß habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Also gegen Corona auch meine.
Ich bin dreimal Corona geimpft
und bei den Kontrollen beim Hausarzt zeige ich immer meinen Impfpass.
Und der Hausarzt ist zufrieden und sagt,
ich habe alle notwendigen Impfungen hier im Mittel für Mittel Europa.
Mehr brauche ich im Augenblick nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit Ausland gewesen
oder eine lange Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich war zwar im Ausland, in Frankreich,
im Herbst für eine Woche.
Aber, nee, sonst habe ich in letzter Zeit Urlaub immer nur in Deutschland gemacht.
Sie haben wenig über Ihre Kopfschmerzen berichten
und haben Sie gefühlt, dass eine blitzende Schmerzen in Ihrem Nacken lag?
Ich habe gar keine Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe Beinschmerzen.
Bein, ja.
Beine tun weh.
Das ist mehr so ein, ja, manchmal brennt das so, ein brennender Schmerz,
aber manchmal auch ein drückender Schmerz.
Das wechselt.
Das ist aber sehr unangenehm.
Ich würde gerne wieder eine Frage stellen.
Jedes Tag im Glucose messen?
Ich messe mindestens dreimal am Tag Blutzucker, bevor ich spritze.
Je nach Blutzucker spritze ich dann Insulin.
Wie war das?
In letzter Zeit war das eigentlich immer recht gut.
Auch der Zucker Langzeitwert, das habe ich vor vier Wochen messen lassen.
Der letzte Zucker Langzeitwert war bei 6,2.
6,1.
Ich habe die Mundgeräusche, die meine Familie und ich sagen.
Mundgeruch oder Mundgeruch?
Mundgeruch, ja.
Nein, wir wurden mir bisher nicht berichtet, dass ich Mundgeruch habe.
Aber die Müdigkeit?
Ja, das habe ich.
Der hat ja auch mit dem Kollegen mich schon gefragt.
Ich fühle mich schon seit der Zeit, seitdem das mit den Augen ist,
auch ziemlich müde und nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Im Studio, Fitnessstudio kann ich nicht mehr so gut trainieren.
Das spüre ich schon.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Mein Schlaf ist eigentlich weiterhin gut.
Der war immer gut und auch jetzt in den letzten Wochen war er gut.
Vielleicht, weil ich auch so erschöpft bin.
Könnte mir als das Display anfangen?
Ja.
Hallo Herr Erwart.
Ich habe heute einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, würde ich ganz gern vorstellen.
Okay.
Und Frau Krusemann ist 41-Jährige-Patientin.
Ich störte sich bei uns wegen der seit zwei Wochen bestehenden
Zähstörung und Doppelbilder.
Ich habe eine Beinschmerzung über die Beinschmerzen.
Es gibt auch Leistungskneken, Verwarschungen,
Verwarschungssprache und diese Symptome treten am Ende die Aufgaben
oder die Aktivitäten.
Die verstecken sich immer weiter.
Sie berichtet auch über Kribben am Beinen
in Continent hat sie auch berichtet, aber das ist nicht wie eine, ja das ist eine
Kontrollverlust, äh ja, kann ich so...
Kontrollverlust am Ende der Emission, am Ende der Emission.
Okay.
Und ansonsten, ja, die Tadea Nese, die ist auf dem Kontinent, ist unauffällig und ja, sie leidet
an Diabetes im Mittel des Typ 1 und natürlich in Zylentpflichtig, ja, und, äh,
Spritz, sich Spritz, äh, ihre Zylent, nach in Zylentchemata und äh, ja, sie, äh, erzählt auch über
Schutdröseninfektion und ich vermute, dass eine Herrscher-Motto-Troiditis ist und äh, sie
nehme ein regelmäßig, äh, Trogzine 50 Mikrogramm ein und, äh, ja, ein Okan-Doctomy, äh, bei,
äh, bei der Patienten, äh, mit äh, ja, äh, mit 10 Jahre alt, schon durchgeführt und,
äh, keine Allergien bekannt und, äh, ja, keine Noxen, äh, anderen Nese, und angeblich, äh,
Ristate und äh, ja, in der, in der anderen Anlamese, äh, ja, ihre Vater, äh, leidet an
Atelier-Dachypathonie und, äh, ja, ja, zeitlich hab ich das schon vergessen, aber, äh, er hat auch,
äh, ein, mir, hat mir, hat ihn faktisch gehabt und jetzt, äh, gut eingestellt, äh, sie auch berichtet
und, äh, bei ihrer Mutter, äh, ja, Knieratose und, äh, die wird das Mädeltus schon bekannt und, äh, sie hat
ein Schwester, ganz gesund und ein Bruder, äh, erleidet, äh, auch Atelier-Dachypathonie und geht, äh,
und, äh, sie ist, äh, verheiratet und arbeitet als Sand-Technikerin, äh, und eigentlich, ja, berichtet
sie über keine Stress-Iterial-Ladensstation. Okay. Und ja, verdacht diagnostisch, denke ich an,
äh, er haben jetzt eine Grösse, äh, die beschwerden, äh, ja, Versteck sich beim Aktivitäten, äh, ja,
und, äh, aber, äh, denke auch, äh, defensial diagnostisch, äh, so, äh, auch kann das, äh, ja,
multipostizidieröser sein oder, äh, die erste Diagnose habe ich nicht verstanden. Was, was?
Mir ist Daniel Gravis. Okay, mir ist Daniel Gravis, ja, okay. Mhm. Und, äh,
defensial diagnostisch kann auch, äh, ja, transostolische iskimische Attac auch infrage
kommen und, ja, aber das ist, ich glaube, ein bisschen untypisch, äh, für diese Patienten.
Mhm. Mhm. Gut. Ja, okay. Sie haben ja die, eine Verdachtstiagnose gestellt und auch
Differenzialdiagnosen und dann werden wir gleich ja nochmal schauen, äh, was ich meinte,
vielleicht, es ist, ja, okay. Gut, ähm, ich denke, Sie haben, äh, das systematisch erfasst und
systematisch berichtet, äh, was aber auffällt ist, äh, und da müssen Sie dran denken in der Prüfung,
dass sie mehr medizinische Fachbegriffe einmachen. Bei der Schilderung haben Sie gesagt, die
Patientin berichtet über seit zwei Wochen bestehende Sehstörungen,
doppelt, dann dann, äh, Visustörung, tatsächlich,
und eventuell, die Plopie. Diplopie. Visustörung, Diplopie, äh, dann, äh, ja, Beinschmerzen,
das natürlich, kann man so ein bisschen, könnte man eventuell, äh, noch beschreiben, wenn man ihn
noch mehr einpracht, vielleicht, äh, es gab, äh, Sie berichtet über Kribbeln, das haben Sie auch
gesagt, dann würde ich mindestens sagen, Kribbeln, Parästhesien, ja, Parästhesien.
Parästhesien. Mhm. Ähm, dann, äh, Sie berichtet über, ähm, Mikzons, ähm,
Beschwerden, äh, am Ende der Mikzon, äh, über einen gewissen Kontrollverlust, also
über eine relative Inkontinenz, am Ende der Mikzons. Ähm, ähm, dann der Diabetes-Militus-Typ 1,
haben Sie gesagt, die Hashimoto-Tyrotheotitis, haben Sie erwähnt, das ist gut, Appendectomie war dabei,
äh, beim Arter, die Atherielle-Hypertomie und, äh, der Myopathinfarkt, bei der Mutter, hatten Sie, äh,
Diabetes-Militus-Typ 2 erwähnt, aber dann haben Sie gesagt, Kniatrose,
Was werden Sie? Konatrose. Konatrose, ja. Konatrose ist wichtig und der Bruder hat eine
Kindheit, aber über dem Oberarzt würde ich schon sagen, eine Hyperurikämie,
beziehungsweise Arthritis-Urika. Ja. Er hat ja nicht nur eine Hyperurikämie, sondern er hat ja wohl
eine symptomatische Hyperurikämie im Sinne einer Arthritis-Urika. Mhm. Das würde ich in
alle Fälle, ähm, versuchen noch als medizinische Fachbegriffe, äh, einzumachen. Na? Also Visusminderung,
das ist so das erste Patentin, 14 Tage über eine Visusminderung, äh, über gelegentliche
Diplopie, über Leistungsknicken oder Fatigue, äh, Symptomatik, äh, Symptomatik, äh,
so. Ähm, ich würde als Verdachtstiagnose sagen, Verdachtstiagnose auf Encephalomyelitis
Disseminata, weil ich glaube, äh, der Beginn mit den Sehstörungen, diese Beinschmerzen, äh,
äh, mit, äh, vielleicht auch Sensibilitätstörungen, mit, äh, Störungen in der Urin-Kontrolle, äh,
das hat für mich eher so ein systemischen Charakter und nicht unbedingt beziehlich einer
Myosthenia Gravis. Also, äh, wäre vielleicht Differenzialdiagnose. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Man kann natürlich jetzt noch dazusagen, die Patientin hat ja einen langbestehenden Diabetes
Melitus, äh, hat sie vielleicht auch eine diabetesche Neuropathie, Polyneuropathie, äh,
ich hab das da extra wieder reingebracht, äh, etwas zu verwirren, aber sie haben sich nicht
ausgedacht. Ähm, ja, das wäre besser, wenn ich ja, das erwähnen könnte. Der Prüfung dran denken,
äh, die, in aller Ruhe, den medizinischen, gerade bei der, bei der Schilderung der, der Erstsymptomatik,
die berichtet wird. Also, ich habe, Patientin sagt, ich kann nicht mehr richtig sehen,
ich sehe verschwommen oder ich sehe mehr Suppelbilder, dann sollten Sie das wirklich
umsetzen in die medizinische Sprache, weil das ein wichtiger Eindruck von dem Robert hat,
dass Sie gleich sagen Visusbinderung, Visusbinderung.
Visusbinderung.
Auch wird über Diplopie berichtet.
Und äh, das ist, glaube ich, ganz sinnvoll. Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bald Prüfung?
Äh, ich, ja, nächste Woche Donaster, glaube ich. Ja.
Ja, da können Sie bis dahin ja noch etwas trainieren, dass Sie gleich immer die, die,
sagen wir mal, Laienbegriffe umsetzen in das medizinische. Das haben Sie zu 60 Prozent
gemacht, aber eben ein, einige haben, wäre noch gut, wenn Sie die dazu bringen.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Ja, natürlich weiter.
Für Ihnen, für die Prüfung dann.
Entschuldigung, äh, für die Mioalitisiminat, das heißt Mutibusikrosa.
Multiplisklerose oder Encephalomioilitis disseminata.
Das ist der Welcherisikofaktören oder Ursachen.
Ja, das weiß man ja nicht genau. Man, man denkt auch, dass es eventuell
eine Autoimmunerkrankung ist, aber die, die, es ist, glaube ich,
sind mehrere Faktoren, die jetzt dazu führen, aber eine richtig exakte
Ursache der MS hat man bis heute noch nicht genau gefunden.
Ja, diese Patiente gibt es akut auf 13er, diese Beschwerden.
Oder Sie, Sie haben gesagt langsam aufgetreten, hat, ich habe die Beschwerden.
Aber seit zwei Wochen, seit zwei Wochen, ja, seit zwei Wochen, das gibt es
schon und dann kommen die Patienten auch, weil sie das sehr irritiert.
Die warten, habe ich meine Erfahrung, war sie, die warten nicht so lange
mit ihrem Beschwerden wie vielleicht Patienten, schlechten Stuhlgang.
sondern die merken plötzlich ich kann nicht mehr richtig sehen das ist ein Alarmsymptom für viele
ich mag meine Beine schmerzen ich kann im studio nicht mehr so gut trainieren wie sonst weil ich
so kaputt bin so müde bin und das ist ja ein Ausdruck dieser Systemerkrankung des
zentralen Nervensystems und die Patienten kommen eigentlich finde ich nach meiner
Erfahrung relativ schnell in die klinik oder in die praxis und schildern sehr diffuse
beschwerden oft sind es ja gar nicht so viele gleichzeitig wie ich jetzt genannt habe sondern
ich habe Patienten gehabt die haben gesagt ich habe so ein eigenartiges kribbeln in den Beinen
oder so und das wird dann schlimmer man ist ja nicht sofort bei dieser Verdachtdiagnose aber
ja die Patienten stellen sich glaube ich relativ schnell vor weil es die sehr unruhig gerade wenn
die wenn die Augen wenn sie nicht mehr gut sehen können plötzlich das ist für viele ein Alarmsymptom
und Diagnose zu erhalten sollen wir ja schädeln
heute tag wird einmal als Basis als als Basis Diagnostik ein Kernspin gemacht
Kernspin des Schädels der Wirbelsäule und gegebenenfalls eine Likopumption
aber ich glaube Kernspin ist heutzutage eigentlich der Goldstandard
aber in der Neurologie werden natürlich weitere Untersuchungen gemacht und wahrscheinlich
wird dann auch Likopumptiert um dort entsündlich Aktivität festzustellen aber oft ist es so dass
im Kernspin schon diese Herde nachweisbar sind und ja die Symptome wenn ich nicht ihre treten
meistens anfassartig auf ja glaube ich kann sein aber ich ich denke dieses ganze Symptombild ist
vielschichtig sehr sehr vielseitig und das macht das eben auch gerade im Anfang so etwas
tückisch deswegen werden manche glaube ich dieser fälle im Anfang erst mal nicht unbedingt als
Verdacht Richtung einer Multiplensklerose gedeutet aber ja aber heutzutage sind glaube ich gerade
durch nrt die möglichkeiten schon sehr gut das auch relativ zeitig zu diagnostizieren man muss
natürlich nur in diese richtigen Sachen dann auch denken das ist klar und das Haupthalter ist
glaube ich nach wie vor zwischen 20 und 40 erkrankungsalter und deutlich mehr frauen als
Männer und ich glaube die ist nicht heilenbar krankei aber inzwischen ist ich glaube ich ganz gut
behandelbar durch bestimmte interferone und was auch die körper da hat sich glaube ich sehr viel
entwickelt in den letzten 20 jahren und manche verläufe sind ja sehr aggressiv die laufen wirklich
mit ständiger verschlechterung und manche bleiben über jahre auch stationär ohne große
verschlimmerung und einzelne schübe aber das ist sehr glaube ich sehr unterschiedlich habe ich das auch